Äh, ja.
Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Äh, ich bin Erdem Özerb und auf dieser Station als Assistenar-Static.
Für Sie bin ich heute der zuständige Arzt.
Deswegen würde ich mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschritt durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Abend Herr Doktor.
Ich bin damit einverstanden, wobei ich habe schon von Ihnen gehört,
sondern ein sehr guter Arzt sein.
Danke Ihnen.
Sie lernen noch neu, aber Sie können schon sehr gut Deutsch sprechen.
Das freut mich.
Ja, das freut mich. Danke Ihnen.
Zuerst stelle ich einige Fragen für Ihre persönlichen Daten
und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie danach,
wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Marina Haage.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Haage ist Hans-Anton Gustav Emil.
Haage.
Unheim ist Marina.
Ja, okay. Haage.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,62 m.
Sie wollen sich auch wissen, wie schwer ich bin.
Ich wiege 65 Kilo.
Wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 18. November 1966.
18. November 1966.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Metzgerin.
Ich arbeite in einer Metzgerei.
Ja, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Okay, Frau Haage.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe eine Schmerz im Halsbereich.
Ich fahre die Hand auf die rechte Seite.
Das schmerzt mir.
Auf der rechten Seite mehr.
Auf der rechten Seite.
Ich merke, dass meine Stimme heiser ist.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen schluckwisch.
Haben Sie Schmerz beim Schluck?
Wenn ich schluckwisch, dann schmerzt das.
Das tut weh.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit drei Tagen wird das schlimmer.
Seit drei Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Sind diese Beschwerden plötzlich
oder sind Sie langsam aufgetreten?
Also, sie kamen plötzlich.
Seit drei Tagen.
Aber ich fühle mich seit längerem schon nicht sehr wohl.
Also, das ist auch ein bisschen komisch.
Einigen Wochen schon.
Und mit der Seite sind diese Beschwerden
schlinm, oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Ich fühle mich immer schlechter.
Deswegen bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen.
Hatten Sie früher solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Also, diese Halsschmerzen hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist neu, aber ich fühle mich halt nicht so gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie in dieser Seite etwas dagegen probiert?
Ein Medikament oder?
Ich habe uns immer so Schmerzen, Medikament genommen.
Aber das hilft mir nichts.
Was hatten Sie angenommen?
Ich habe es in einem Medikament gegessen.
Schmerzen sind irgendwo hin auch?
Hier am Hals? Nein, das ist eher im Halsbereich.
Nur im Hals, ja.
Sind besonders die Schmerzen dauerhaft?
Oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Das ist eher so ein bisschen wellenartig.
Es gibt Phasen, da ist es stärker.
Dann gibt es wiederum Phasen.
Da ist es weniger, aber es ist eigentlich immer da.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Beispielsweise Kalte trinken?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Wenn ich etwas trinke oder esse, dann schmerzt das beim Schlucken.
Egal was.
Auch unabhängig davon, ob es warm oder kalt ist.
Aber für sich ist es egal.
Nur wenn ich an Schmerz tabule, dann habe ich für 1-2 Stunden etwas Ruhe.
Aber das geht dann wieder los.
Ich merke auch, dass meine Stimme seit heute heiser ist.
Sie merken mir, das ist jetzt ganz komisch geworden.
Seit heute haben Sie die...
Zum ersten Mal kamen Sie zu einem Astier wegen dieser Beschwörung.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich in der Stimme geblieben.
Ich habe mich in der Stimme geblieben.
Wie gesagt, ich fühle mich seit Wochen schon etwas unwohl.
Seit 2-3 Tagen ist es schlimmer geworden.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Weil 1 sehr leicht und 6 stark entschiebt?
Wie ich schon sagte, es gibt Situationen, da ist es stark.
Da würde ich schon sagen, für 6 bis 7.
Dann gibt es auch mal Stunden.
Da ist es für 6 bis 7 Stunden.
Dann gibt es auch mal Stunden, da ist es vielleicht 2 Stunden.
Wie sind diese Schmerzen?
Die sind drückend, siehend, brennend.
Ja, das ist eher so ein bisschen...
zum Teil stechend und manchmal auch ein bisschen drückend.
Aber ich fühle mich etwas krank.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Ich habe mich auch ein bisschen drückend.
Sind diese Beschwerden...
Ja, natürlich.
Mit der Messung sind diese Beschwerden verbunden.
Aber mit der Lage oder mit der Bewegung sind diese Beschwerden auch verbunden?
Ja, verbunden.
Ich glaube, ich habe es halt immer, auch wenn ich laufe.
Oder lege.
Beispielsweise können Sie flach liegen.
Ja, da habe ich trotzdem die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Oder...
Ja, tagsüber haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Oder beispielsweise Besonderes morgens sind diese Beschwerden...
Schlimmer oder mit der Seite am Tag...
Ja, ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich habe immer...
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Schlafsrost?
Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht, aber ich fühle mich schon etwas schlapp, erschöpft.
Ich merke, dass ich Herzrasen habe.
Immer wieder so eine innere Unruhe.
Was mir auffällt, ist, ich schwitze jetzt seit einigen Tagen.
Sehr stark.
Meine Hände sind ganz nass.
Und...
Und ich schlafe da auch ganz schlecht.
Ja, okay.
Und seit einigen Tagen haben Sie diese Beschwerden auch?
Ja, genau, das hat zubenommen, ja.
Das habe ich früher schon gemacht, ich sage ja jeden Tag.
Ich bin seit einigen Wochen fühle ich mich nicht wohl.
Aber das ist jetzt schlimmer geworden, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen übeln und dann haben Sie auch Erbrechen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, aber ich fühle mich sehr geschwächt.
Und haben Sie Schlaffprobleme?
Ja, Sie haben Schlaffprobleme, aber haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen jetzt nicht.
Stuhlgang ist manchmal ein bisschen weich und breich.
Ich vermute, dass es fast zu einem Durchfall wird, aber bisher habe ich noch keinen Durchfall gehabt.
Ist da weicherer, ja?
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor den Augen?
Nein, das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Haben Sie Erbrechen verloren?
Nein, das habe ich auch noch nicht.
Ich weiß noch nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Es ist gut, ich esse von Trinke und ich habe auch in letzter Zeit etwas abgenommen, merke ich.
Über Wercher-Seite haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, in zwei, drei Wochen habe ich schon drei, vier Kilo abgenommen.
In zwei, drei Wochen haben Sie ungefähr drei, vier Kilo abgenommen?
Nein, vier, drei, vier, vier, vier Kilo abgenommen.
Obwohl ich noch mal esse.
Okay.
Ja.
Sie sind seit Ihnen...
Was wollen Sie denn machen, Herr Doktor? Was glauben Sie? Ist das was Schlimmes?
Ja, derzeit ist es für etwas genaues Sagen zuerst.
Ich muss Anamnese fertig machen und dann ja für ich einige Buluttes und so weiter führen.
Aber wir sprechen darüber, ja? Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ja bitte.
Mach mir schon.
Wie lange sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Ja, das habe ich schon längst hinter mir, über zehn Jahre hier.
Das habe ich glücklicherweise hinter mir.
Okay, besuchen Sie regelmäßig einen Frauenarzt oder eine Frauenarzt?
Nein, ich gehe regelmäßig zu meinen Frauenarzt, der man das alles in Ordnung macht, seine Konkurrenz.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, beispielsweise Blutzuckerkrankheit oder Blutwortrück?
Ja, glücklicherweise nicht.
Ich habe ein bisschen chronisches Kniebproblem rechts.
Da ist liegt eine Art Rose vor, wenn man Orthopäde meint, das muss man vielleicht irgendwann mal operieren, aber das will ich abwarten, solange es geht.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, noch nicht, aber mein Orthopäde meint, das muss man vielleicht in ein, zwei Jahren operieren.
Okay, in Ihrer nachher verwendeten Schaft gibt es auch einige wichtige Erkrankungen, beispielsweise Bluthochdruck und Blutzuckerkrankheit, Krebserkrankungen.
Das wüsste ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Bei Ihren Eltern, Geschwistern und...
Kein gesund.
Okay, haben Sie Allergie gegen Oder-Unverträglichkeit gegen etwas?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie gegen eine Antibiotik. Ich glaube, das ist Amoxicillin.
Okay.
Okay, wie oisert es sich diese Allergie?
Oh, das war ganz schlimm, Herr Doktor, ich habe einen ganzen Ausschlag am ganzen Körper bekommen,
ich habe viel Yukreis und habe schlecht Luft bekommen, also das war schon ganz schlimm.
Gegen Kontrastmittel haben Sie Allergie?
Nein.
Okay, sind Sie total geimpft gegen wichtige Erkrankungen im Rahmen der M5 und...
Aussage, Schaft, nach und sage, das ist in Ordnung.
Raubhängen Sie?
Ja.
Seit wann und zu wie viel Zigaretten pro Tag?
Herr Doktor, das dürfen Sie mich gar nicht fragen.
Vor 30 Jahren schon leider, ja, aber ich kann leider nicht aufhören.
Ich habe es einmal oder mehrfach schon mal probiert, aber ich rauche schon sehr länger.
Und eine Packung pro Tag oder mehr?
Ja, das habe ich früher geraucht, jetzt sind es so 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal, ja, wenn so ein Fest oder so ist, aber nicht immer.
Was trinken Sie generell?
Ich trinke gerne ein Wein.
Einglas, ja?
Ja, ein Glas oder manchmal auch zwei, ja.
Okay, Frau Haake, das waren alle meine Fragen, meine Meinung nach habe ich alle wichtige Informationen erhalten.
Ja, vielen...
Aber Sie fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich möchte das eigentlich herausfinden, was es ist, ich mache mir so langsam Sorgen, ja.
Ja, wie gesagt, ist das für etwas genauer sagen,
ja, aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich einen Verdach auf, oder Sie haben ein Problem mit der Speiseröhre.
Deswegen sollte ich einige Blut testen und die verfahren durchführen.
Jetzt lege ich Ihnen einen Zugang und gleichzeitig nehme ich Blut ab ein bisschen.
Und nach diesem Massnahmen bespreche ich Ihren Fall mit meinem Oberarzt und dann komme ich zu Ihnen wieder, ja.
Und das machen Sie heute noch?
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Ich hoffe Blut testen und so weiter können wir heute machen.
Aber für Röntgenaufnahme können wir auch heute machen.
Aber für MRT und bei Bedarf City spreche ich auch mit der Abteilung der Radiologie, ja.
Oh, das ist aber sehr nett, da bin ich an der richtigen Adresse, Sie machen ja echt alles.
Vielen Dank.
Wollen wir gleich die Übergabe an Oberarzt machen und dann Differenzialdiagnosen besprechen?
Ja, mit der Anamnese hast du gefragt?
Ja, ich habe gefragt, ja.
Okay.
Pfandumian?
Ja, bitte, ich warte auf Sie, genau.
Okay, guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Ah, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ja, heute habe ich einen neuen Patientin, nämlich Marina Haage, aufgenommen.
Okay.
Über diesen Patient möchte ich mit Ihnen sprechen.
Hätten Sie dafür Zeit?
Aber natürlich für Sie doch immer Herr Dr. Büdischven.
Okay, danke Ihnen, ja.
Okay, Frau Haage ist eine 65-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,62 m groß und 65 kg schwer.
Sie arbeitet als Metzgerin und sei verheiratet und habe eine Tochter.
Sie stellte sich uns wegen einigen Tagen bestehender Halsschmerzen.
Besonders auf der rechten Seite bestehender Schmerzen.
Und seit heute bestehender Heiserkeit.
Und Odino Fagi und Dysfagi Foa.
Und diese Beschwerden seien plötzlich aufgetreten und prokredienter.
Früher wurden die Fragen bis zu regenden Beschwerden verneint.
Diese Beschwerden haben Sie über 400 mg einmal eingenommen.
Aber dieses Medikament hat nichts gebracht.
Es gibt keine Ausschätzung und es gibt viele Artikel.
Aber Sie sagten so, diese Beschwerden seien eigentlich immer da.
Und es gibt auch Nahrungsabhängige.
Egal ob Flüssigkeit oder feste Nahrung.
Zum ersten Mal sei sie zu einem Ast gekommen.
Und auf einer Skala liegen die Schmerzen, würden die Schmerzen 2-7 liegen.
Die Schmerzen seien stehend und drückend.
Außer den Klackten die Patienten über Fatiguë, Tashulkardi und Schwitzeln in Sonnier und Nausea.
Die Fragen nach Emesis und Problemen beim Wasserlassen.
Und Vertigo, Peristalsigkeit und in Abpätens wurden verneint.
Aber sein Schutul sei bis der Weich.
Und manchmal fühle sie es gibt Diary.
Aber sie konnten nicht genau sagen.
Obwohl ihr Appetit ganz gut ist, klackte sie über Gewichtabnahme in 2-3 Wochen, ungefähr 3-4 Kilogramm.
Die Patientin sei im Kliemakterium über 10 Jahre.
Und sie besuchte regelmäßig einen Trauernarzt.
Und war alles in Ordnung, hatte sie so gesagt.
Die Fragen nach chronischen Erkrankungen und der Operation wurden verneint.
Und Familien an einem Nese sei auch unauffällig.
Sie haben Allergie gegen Amoxicillin mit dieser Allergie äußert.
Sie haben mit Ausschlag, Prioritis und Prismine.
Im Status sei total.
Seit 30 Jahren rauchte sie ungefahr sein, das heißt 4-5-Jährige.
Und gelegentlich trinken sie Alkohol, Wein.
Sie haben das schön zusammengefasst.
Was ist Ihr Verdacht?
Meine Verdacht, Diagnose ist eigentlich Osefagus carcinoma.
Osefagus carcinoma?
Ja, wegen Odeonophagia und besonders Gewichtabnahme.
Sie ist auch Raucher.
Sie denken an einen maligenden Prozess.
Sie haben eine gute Untersuchung mitmachen.
Warum denken Sie noch?
Differenzialdiagnose.
Sie haben eine Frage mit Fieber.
Ja, Fieber hat nichts.
Aber ich weiß, habe Sie.
Ja, hier ist ganz wichtig.
In Kürzer seit 4 Kilogramm hat sie verloren.
Deswegen hatte ich maligmense gedacht.
Und dann ja, und Tachy-Karpi gibt es auch.
Was sind Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Ich kann so sagen.
Einige Kollegen beschrieben.
Gastro, Osefagiallioreflu.
Neuflux, okay.
Neuflux.
Und dann Magengcarcinoma.
Oder Lungencarcinoma.
Ganz weit, aber ja.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Und dann ja, Hypertroise oder Hypertroise.
Sie denken an die Schilddröse.
Das ist ein Hinweis.
Schilddrösen unterfunktionen, denke ich.
Hypertroise.
Okay, was?
Ja, wegen Tachy-Karpi kann man Hypertroise,
aber das kann auch Reflex-Tachy-Karpi sein.
Aber hier gibt es auch Fatigua.
Deswegen sollte es, ich denke, Hypertroise.
Okay.
Diagnose, Differenzialdiagnose, das wird sich im Labor,
kann man feststellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Woran denken Sie noch?
Ganz einfach.
Lymphoma.
Auch wieder was Malignis, Woran denken Sie noch?
Die Kollegen.
Halschmerz, nur ist tot weh.
Toncilitis.
Ja, Toncilitis.
Larin geht es.
Und da, was kann da etwas Bösartiges sein?
Ein Larin-Karzinom.
Ja, wegen Heiserkeit.
Stim-Lippen-Karzinom.
Ich habe einige junge Patienten, die haben wirklich einen Stim-Lippen-Karzinom.
Zestelle.
Okay.
Halt jemand sonst noch eine Idee?
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Das war sehr gut.
Wir haben das schön gut im Überblick.
Sie müssen auch ein bisschen auf den Patienten eingehen.
Der Patient hat gesagt, es geht im Scheid länger.
Schon nicht so gut.
Er fühlt sich schlecht.
Vielleicht hätten Sie dann fragen müssen, was genau ist schlecht.
Welche Symptome haben Sie?
Das haben Sie aber nicht gemacht. Das haben wir erst viel, viel später.
Das kann man machen. Aber sonst war das sehr gut.
Auch das Vortragen.
Sehr gut.
Hauptsymptome sind über Speiseröhre.
Deswegen sollte man auch fragen.
Ich sage jetzt, was es war.
Das war jetzt ein Patient aus meiner Praxis.
Bis zum Depressiv-Jahr.
Wir haben Laburwerte gemacht.
Und dann kam raus.
Tsh unter 0,01.
T3 über 20, also sehr hoch.
T4 über 40, sehr hoch.
Zildrösen Antipyropa sehr hoch.
Und alles andere war völlig unauffällig.
Was hat diese Frau?
Eine akute Hypertyriose.
Woran?
Hyroditis.
Die gute Schilddrösen in Entzündung.
Macht auch solche Schmerzen.
Diese Frau hat eine akute Hypertyriose.
Ich habe mit dem Entenkrinologen telefoniert.
Wir haben sofort eine Therapie bekommen.
Welche Therapie gibt man bei einer Hypertyriose?
Bei Basedorf zum Beispiel.
Man gibt Tyriosthatica.
Wie nennt sich das?
Metamizol.
Metamizol ist Novalgien.
Das ist gegen die Schmerzen.
Karbimazol ist das Medikament.
Und wegen der Tachikadie gibt man Betablokka.
Welches?
Propranolol.
Und das kann jetzt dauern.
Was gegen die Schmerzen?
Ibuprofen.
Bei einer akuten Tyrioditis
erwarten wir ein sehr hohes CHP.
Aber das hat die Patientin jetzt nicht.
Hätte sie ein hohes CHP über 100,
dann wäre das eine akute Tyrioditis.
Und die kann man auch mit Cortison behandeln.
Was für ein Facharzt sind Sie, Herr Kollege?
Ja, Pharmakologie.
Sie sind Pharmakologe?
Dann kennen Sie die ganzen Medikamente.
Sehr gut. Wunderbar. Vielen Dank.